wir beginnen unsere recherche in cottbus
die zweitgrößte stadt brandenburgs ist
immer wieder schauplatz rechter
mobilmachung seit einem jahr
organisieren radikale rechte auch
demonstrationen gegen die krone
schutzmaßnahmen an diesem sonntag im
februar 2021 ist es eine cottbuser
initiative mit dem unverfänglichen namen
bürger für bürgerrechte
vorbildlich sagen das ist wieder rechts
noch links noch sonst etwas
wir sind am ende alle eins nämlich eine
große menschenfamilie wir sind das volk
und wir sind erst überreden
bereits im oktober 2020 mobilisierte der
rechtsextreme vereinszukunft heimat mit
einer anti corona demo fast 500 menschen
immer wieder rufen akteure die der
radikalen rechten zugeordnet werden zu
aktionen gegen die korona politik auf
sven bogacz kennt diese gruppen der
leiter der polizeidirektion brandenburg
süd beobachtet seit langem ihre
kundgebungen und weiß wer daran
teilnimmt
das sind personen die teilweise mit der
situation unzufrieden sind
wir haben aber ist das auch in den
ersten versammlungen deutlich rechts
rechtsextremisten in den versammlungen
spüren können logisch ist verantwortlich
für den schutz von über 600.000 menschen
in der region die radikale rechte
beschäftige ihn in seiner arbeit
besonders natürlich könnte es eine sehr
schöne stadt ich sagte ich bin hier
geboren aufgewachsen
wenn dann der ruf und cottbus durch eine
minderheit geprägt wird die keinen guten
ruf staat stellt dann ist es schon eine
unschöne situation 2009 10 watt der
landesverfassungsschutz die stadt werde
in teilen dominiert von einem toxischen
gebilde ein netzwerk aus rechtsextremen
hooligans und kampfsportlern die auch
teile der lokalen wirtschaft prägen wie
gastronomie und sicherheitsunternehmen
die radikale rechte ringe hier seit
jahrzehnten um einfluss erzählt uns
bürger bomberjacke und springerstiefel
seien kaum noch zu sehen
man gebe sich eher bürgerlich sie
versucht diese mitte der gesellschaft zu
erreichen das ist mit gewalt schwer
möglich und sie sucht einen anderen
möglichkeiten platz in der gesellschaft
anerkennung zu finden
über wirtschaftliche aktivitäten über
events hinter dem vermeintlich harmlosen
auftreten steckt eine strategie die
radikale rechte möchte breitere
gesellschaftliche schichten für sich
gewinnen
in ganz deutschland das beobachtet der
rechtsextremismus forscher matthias
quendt cottbus ist keine ausnahme es
gibt viele andere regionen in denen sich
ähnliches abgespielt
quendt leitet in jena das institut für
demokratie und zivilgesellschaft
seit jahren erforscht er radikale rechte
bewegungen deutschlandweit in cottbus
sei die wie er sagt neue rechte
besonders erfolgreich doch das vorgehen
sei überall gleich die neue rechte hat
die strategie ausgegeben unter dem
deckmantel des populismus in die
parlamente in die öffentlichkeit in
breitere bevölkerungsgruppen vorzustoßen
sprechen seit einigen jahren von der
neuen rechten was ist das eigentlich
die neue rechte ist überhaupt nicht neu
es gibt sie seit den ende der 1960 er
jahre als gegenbewegung zu der
sogenannten neuen linken
es ist der versuch eine antiliberale
antidemokratische rechtsradikale politik
neu zu fassen
es ist also eine form von
intellektueller rechtsextremismus der
sich versucht unter bürgerlichen gewand
darzustellen und der versucht vor allem
die grenzen zwischen konservatismus und
rechtsextremismus einzureißen
die neue rechte sequent versuche auch
außerhalb der parlamente ihrer anti
liberalen positionen gesellschaftsfähig
zu machen
mit eigenen kulturangeboten vereinen und
initiativen kann ihr das durch die
verknüpfung mit den protesten auf der
straße und mit der wut auf die korona
politik gelingen
zurück in cottbus
dort ruft bürger für bürgerrechte erneut
zum protest auf diesmal mit einem
autokorso gegen die korona
schutzmaßnahmen die initiative gibt sich
unabhängig tatsächlich zeigen unsere
recherchen die initiatorinnen von bürger
für bürgerrechte traten mehrfach bei dem
vom verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuften verein zukunft heimat auf
ist die initiative bürger für
bürgerrechte in wahrheit ein neuer
rechter tann verein monique bruder mit
organisatorin des autokorsos war zuvor
auch schon bei zukunft heimat aktiv
der verein wird inzwischen vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet es hat
offensichtlich große überschneidung zu
geben von heimat und 8 wir unterstützen
uns natürlich gegenseitig logisch wenn
sich die themen dazu passend sind warum
sollte man sich da nicht gegenseitig
ergänzen zukunft heimat gilt so ein
interner vermerk des verfassungsschutzes
der uns vorliegt als scharnier in die
gewaltbereit und rechtsextreme szene der
stadt
das kann ich jetzt nicht kann ich jetzt
nicht beurteilen
so was ist mir dass sie schon damals nie
aufgefallen dass man mal los
etwa eine stunde nach ende des
autokorsos gibt es vor der stadthalle
eine weitere demonstration aufgerufen
hat diesmal die afd
auch hier ist monique bruder mit dabei
und einige parteiprominenz
der fdp ehrenvorsitzende alexander
gauland und der rechtsextreme andreas
kalbitz der mittlerweile aus der afc
ausgeschlossen wurde
der hauptredner ist hans christoph
berndt er ist fraktionsvorsitzender der
afd in brandenburg und gründer des
vereins zukunft heimat in cottbus
veranstaltet bernd mit seinem verein
seit 2017 fremdenfeindliche
demonstrationen so bezeichnet der
verfassungsschutz die proteste seit
frühjahr 2020 nutzt bernd auch das thema
corona für seine kundgebungen der
verfassungsschutz nennt ihn einen zitat
erwiesenen rechtsextremisten bernd wird
offen sein für möglichst breite allianz
während versucht protest und unmut in
der stadt zu kanalisieren und gibt sich
dabei bewusst bürgerlich
ein interner vermerk des
verfassungsschutzes der zdfzoom vorliegt
sieht das anders
berns vereinszukunft heimat sei
unterwandert von neonazis der
gruppierung spree lichter die wurden
bereits 2012 verboten
bernd und sein verein würden eine zitat
scharnierfunktion zur gewaltbereiten
rechtsextremistischen michéle erfüllen
darüber reden möchte er mit uns nicht
bereits im vorfeld hatten wir ihnen
mehrfach um ein gespräch gebeten
hans christoph berndt und sein verein
zukunft heimat sind ein musterfall der
neurechten strategie ihre radikale
agenda möglichst breiten wirksam zu
propagieren und harmlos erscheinen zu
lassen
bundesweit möchte er diese strategie
voran bringen götz kubitschek bereits
2016 berichtete zdfzoom über dessen
ambitionen überall im land wolle er
eigene bürgerinitiativen gründen wie
zukunft heimat in cottbus
die neue rechte wollen neue schichten
erreichen und sich modern geben
durch eine bestimmte auf den film durch
eine bestimmte art internetauftritt und
eine bestimmte art der
selbstpräsentation dass es überhaupt
kein problem ist und ganz natürlicher
vorgang zu uns herüber zu finden
kubitschek leiter eines kleinen verlages
gilt als einer der haupt strategen der
neuen rechten er trat auf kundgebungen
von zukunft heimat und peggy darauf
sein ziel in allen gesellschaftlichen
bereichen aktiv sein um so das diskurs
fenster nach rechts zu verschieben wie
er auf einer afd strategietagung 2017
erklärte ist die grundaufgabe die kunden
aufgabe unseres politischen initiativen
die unterschiedlichen akteure verbinde
ein gemeinsames ziel sagt
rechtsextremismus experte matthias queck
das bedeutet die die stabilisierung des
glaubens und des vertrauens in die
liberale demokratie um dann auf den
ideologischen ruinen sozusagen des
vertrauens in die liberale demokratie
eine neue rechtsradikale
gesellschaftsordnung zu installieren die
neue rechte suche nach einer neuen krise
in der korona pandemie glaube sie diese
gefunden zu haben und bemühe sich um
neue bündnisse diese allianzen kommen
zusammen allerdings ohne eine große
breitenwirkung dahingehend auszuführen
auszuwirken dass sich menschen ihnen
massenhaft anschließen was allerdings
erfolgreich ist ist diese strategie der
destabilisierung denn das ist ja die
große hoffnung wenn man nur oft genug
von der krone diktatur redet dann bleibt
bei der bevölkerung da auch ein
misstrauen etwas etwas hängen
josef hamburger politikwissenschaftler
und daten spezialist analysiert wie sich
die neue rechte online mit corona
skeptikern vernetzt in den tagen vor dem
versuchten reichstags sturm hat der
oldenburger verstärkte gewaltaufrufe
registriert besonders auf den
messenger-dienst telegramm also da gab
es schon sehr viele eskalationen die
dann wiederum in die realität eben auch
ungeschlagen haben mit diesem versuchten
sturm auf das reichstagsgebäude und da
gab es zum beispiel eine gruppe dieser
bereits seit 23
juni existierte und sturm auf den
reichstag hieß auf den messenger-dienst
telegramm werden selbst hasserfüllte und
gewaltvolle inhalte nicht kontrolliert
auch deswegen hätten viele neue rechte
akteure in den vergangenen jahren
telegram für sich genutzt
in der korona pandemie seien dann auch
viele neue nutzer auf die plattform
gelangt wenn man sich die nutzer in
bewegung generell anguckt dann sieht man
dass da wirklich sehr viele so ab
april/mai mit telegramm hinzugekommen
sind und vorher noch in keiner gruppe
aktiv war
wir sind hier vor allem die größten
kanäle den sehr rasantes wachstum
eingenommen haben über das ganze jahr
verteilt nicht gesehen von der
wachsenden popularität der plattform
profitierten vor allem die neu
entstandenen corona gruppen auf
telegramm konnte die afg und andere
rechte akteure von der pandemie bisher
noch nicht so stark profitieren wir
sehen sehr viele verschwörungs
ideologische akteure die starken
zugewinnen bekommen haben die
mittlerweile über 150 tausend abonnenten
zum beispiel erreichen
die afg hat offizielle kanäle auch oft
telegramm die derzeit aber noch unter
10.000 zum beispiel bleiben
wir bitten josef rollen bürger für uns
zu analysieren inwieweit die afd
beispielhaft für die neue rechte in den
quer denken kanälen mit ihren inhalten
präsenter wird und wie erfolgreich sie
mit ihrer strategie der vereinnahmung
ist unterdessen schauen wir uns einige
der telegramm gruppen aus hollen burgas
datensatz genauer an
wir lesen tausende nachrichten und
stellen dabei fest die gruppen sind
vielfältig und vielschichtig esoteriker
und rechtsradikale besorgte väter und
verzweifelte selbständige kritik an den
maßnahmen mischt sich mit
verschwörungstheorien und antisemitismus
immer wieder lesen wir gewalt aufrufe
und drohungen gegen politik wissenschaft
und medien der ton verschärft sich die
botschaften werden radikaler im oktober
2020 erhängen unbekannte im nordrhein
westfälischen minden symbolisch die
presse
in der örtlichen querdenken gruppe
findet die aktion fürsprecher im februar
2021 wird die querdenken gruppe minden
für eine kundgebung im benachbarten
espelkamp
wir fahren dorthin und wollen einige
demonstrierende persönlich kennenlernen
gegründet wurde die mindener querdenken
gruppe auf initiative lokaler
bürgerinnen und bürgern
[Musik]
auch die örtliche afd mischt mit von
anfang an mit dabei
landtagsabgeordneter thomas röckmann
minden wie auch s bekannt gehören zu
seinen wahlkreis
er ist auch in der lokalen querdenken
telegramm gruppe aktiv wird dort offen
für sich und die afd
bevor wir ihn treffen sprechen wir mit
einem der organisatoren bei unserer
demonstration darf jeder mitlaufen der
unser anliegen mitteilt wir gucken nicht
in sein gehirn wir fragen ihn nicht nach
oder stoßen ab sofern er sich vernünftig
und akkurat verhält also war
linksextremisten dürfen wir uns mit
laufen und wissen sie was waren nichts
mehr können sie will ich auch können sie
mich auch fragen ob ich mich von der
italienischen mafia abgrenzen will oder
so bin ich zwar auch nichts zu tun aber
vielleicht läuft ja einer mit
die afg präsenz gefällt nicht allen eine
partei anhängerin wird von anderen
demonstrierenden aufgefordert ihre afd
maske umzudrehen
[Musik]
wir lassen uns hier nicht von
irgendwelchen aber der afg abgeordnete
thomas röckmann zählt zum äußerst
rechten flügel der partei in nordrhein
westfalen
jetzt waren ja hier bei der demo
durchaus einige widerstände auch gegen
sie haben sie das gefühl sie werden gar
nicht gewollt aber gar nicht ich habe
ganz viele stimmen gehört die gesagt
haben ja schön dass du da bist du dass
sie da sind
also von daher passt das schon sie nicht
mehr regelmäßig an solchen
veranstaltungen teil warum man sagt 30
prozent der querdenken bewegung ist afg
affin
das finde ich schon bemerkenswert zumal
wenn man jetzt heute geguckt hat da
haben sehr viele alt 68er gespielt mit
zöpfchen und für thomas röckmann sind
die querdenker potenziell politische
anhänger und um diese zu umwerben ist
kein vergleich zu groß in der telegramm
gruppe zum beispiel querdenken minden
sprechen sie von der diktatur und sie
wollen gern angela merkel vor gericht im
übrigen meine ich dass die maske
herrschaft herrschaftssymbol für was für
dessen herrschaft dass die herrschaft
von frau merkel
die organisatoren der demonstration
distanzieren sich wenige tage danach von
der teilnahme der afd
thomas brüggemann tritt später aus der
minden telegramm gruppe aus
[Musik]
wir sind wieder mit dem daten analysten
josef holnburger verabredet mit dabei
ist diesmal auch rechtsextremismus
experte matthias queck aus jena wegen
der korona lage ist der virtuell
zugeschaltet wie gut ist es zb der afg
in den vergangenen wochen gelungen
telegram für sich zu nutzen und ihren
einfluss auszubauen
inhalte der afg sind deutlich häufiger
zu finden aber auch die afg eigenen
kanäle wachsen im jahr 2021 das ist ja
nach unserem letzten treffen mitte
januar etwa extrem steil warum gerade in
dieser zeit zwischen januar und april
möglicherweise hat das auch damit zu tun
dass es gerade die jeweiligen
landtagswahlen getroffen hat und man da
mehr intern auch mobilisiert auf jeden
fall hat man vermutlich eine
medienstrategie der angewendeten dieser
kanäle stärker zu publizieren
seine analyse zeigt besonders gut
funktioniert diese strategie beim thema
impfen
das sei in querdenken gruppen in den
vergangenen monaten besonders präsent
und die afg bediene die impfskepsis mit
eigenen inhalten sowie letzten wochen
wir sehen aber auch dass zum beispiel
videos aus dem bundestag der afg häufig
geteilt werden gerade eben wenn sie das
thema zum beispiel impfungen
thematisieren sequenz wir uns zuletzt
sahen haben wir von einer möglichen
allianz bildung gesprochen insofern kann
es erfolgreich sein und da können sowohl
impfgegner als auch die afg voneinander
profitieren denn die einen sitzen in den
parlamenten und die anderen sind in der
lage straßenproteste zu einem aktuellen
thema zu mobilisieren und das hier
politikverdrossenheit populismus oder
eben auch radikale bewegungen gestärkt
werden aber wir sehen dass die afg
wahltaktisch insgesamt teil davon bisher
nicht profitieren kann
neue rechte aktivisten versuchen
verunsicherung und wut für sich zu
nutzen
homburgers datenanalyse zeigt online
haben sie damit teilweise erfolg
in der breiteren öffentlichkeit kann sie
damit bisher zwar noch nicht punkten
doch langfristig ziele die strategie der
neuen rechten auf etwas anderes ihrer
agenda gesellschaftsfähig zu machen
[Musik]